[Music]
[Applause]
Wright Thompson has a story about uh
Lionel Messi and his relationship with
his hometown and it's in the cost of
these dreams that's a collection that uh
Wright has written stories on Michael
Jordan Tiger Woods Ted Williams Messi
the greatest of all time untold stories
and the cost of their greatness that is
available when that first came out right
came on and thanked us because it went
to number one on the New York Times
bestseller list well you know I mean
your fans are uh I mean I hope you send
out Christmas cards because people
evidently love you because they do
whatever you say
uh but no I appreciate it how you doing
this morning Dan I'm doing great I did
think of you and you did such a deep
dive on Messi and trying to understand
the importance of this uh Maradona that
shadow two different personalities and
um what did you take away or what were
you taking away from this world cup
messy related
I mean I was watching last night
thinking that uh or watching yesterday
morning I apologize just thinking that
I don't know this sounds weird and
slightly over dramatic but I mean I
think it's true that he had bought his
way back home that I mean for people who
don't know he's from a town called
Rosario in Argentina and he uh left when
he was 12 or 13 years old and the reason
he left is Messi would not be messy were
it not for medical intervention like he
needed a regiment of growth hormone or
they said he was going to end up being
you know very very very shorter than he
is now and uh the club that he played
for in Argentina or the Argentinian
Football Federation refused his family's
begs frankly to pay for this and
Barcelona stepped up and was like we got
it and he moved to Barcelona and became
Leo Messi and so there are two things
going on one when he needed his hometown
most they weren't there and then on the
other side uh people I like just
idolized Diego Maradona and you just
couldn't have two different figures than
sort of quiet graceful brilliant uh uh
messy and wild out of control
uh mayor Donna and you know not to deal
in generalities but you know Maradona
very closely fit into the national ID of
Argentina and the way that anybody
that's sort of a gunslinger in America
evokes sort of the Great American Myth
that's why we loved Brett Favre uh you
know uh Maradona fit into that and Messi
didn't and you know they're in in Spain
they thought he was Argentinian in
Argentina they thought he was Spanish
and he was just a man without a home
his style
that you know you see mbappe you know he
he is that's raw athleticism he's he's
he attacks he's an animal but Messi is
sort of that water torture that Here
Comes Here It Comes Here Comes Here
Comes it just keeps keeps keeps and then
all of a sudden the faucet opens there
but how would you and your elegant
eloquent way uh describe him well you
know the thing I keep thinking about is
the player he was yesterday was not who
he was at the very beginning I mean
there were flashes of it but you know if
you go on YouTube and and search Messi
doesn't dive you will see these
incredible moments of athleticism and
he's just a guy who at the end of the
day like all of those athletes that we
admire whether it's Jordan or Tom Brady
or whomever uh he wanted to win and as
you know age and time caught up with him
he changed his game to still be able to
play and you know that guy on that field
I mean first of all no one should have
lost that game might be the best game
I've ever watched in my life and we were
screaming at our television and uh but
that guy who walked off that field of
Victor uh earned that you know and and
like a very real way that I found deeply
emotional that like he earned that
and I'm watching and and I I get to do
this all the time I don't know about you
right I'm just rooting for what's the
great story didn't matter in France or
Argentina won because it was going to be
a great story either way but to watch
with people who don't have a rooting
interest because the drama was what the
rooting interest was and just do we have
that in college I mean any sport here
that comes close to capturing that
you know I'm sure that I'm sure there is
I'm sure it's very siled and Regional I
mean it's hard to find something that
matters where the morality play is
written so large you know and also
there's you know I just love to listen
to the soccer announcers because you
know I mean the way American Sports are
commentated it's very much like you know
there's the mic in the pipe and he's
trying to keep a high line and the
quarterback's going through his
progressions and here's the safety Blitz
coming through the a gap and just you
know and then the soccer announcer is
they are overcoming the ghost of the
generals you know it's just like it's
like it's like we need some of that like
I don't need to know what the defense is
you know tell me what it means and so I
mean some of that is just the way the
sport exists in the consciousness of the
people who love it uh but no I mean the
drama was incredible I mean I watched it
with my mother who couldn't care less
and when the penalty kick started she
got up and left the room and I'm like
where are you going and she said those
are all Somebody's Baby and I can't
watch this
I'm wondering the personality of Messi
that sometimes you'll see somebody on
the field and then they're different off
the field a lot of times they are and I
don't know what that personality is uh
off the field and on the field if they
if they intersect at any point you know
it's uh you know there's a great story
uh uh an ESPN journalist Named Sam
Borden wrote I think he wrote I don't
remember if he wrote it for us or for
the New York Times or we used to work
for but he went to Argentina and sort of
went through Messi's life and one of the
things that was so interesting is you
almost wish all those people in
Argentina who said oh he doesn't love
his country could have seen this because
he was living in Argentinian life in a
Spanish City you know he was very you
know he's married to someone he grew up
with and uh he has friends who moved
over there with him there's an
Argentinian butcher nearby where he buys
all of his meat you know so he was
living
essentially in this kind of Argentinian
Exile a long long way from home and uh
you know it it's there's a reason he
hasn't been in the tabloids like Diego
maradano with you know uh a wrecked
portion an eight ball you know I mean
like like he's a guy who wants to be
great at this one thing and is great at
it
yeah and I I once he won I I thought is
this it like are you are you now able to
go to the MLS let's say could you see
could you see Messi doing that
you know it's interesting I certainly
thought well that's it he's going to
rise right off into the sunset I saw a
news story this morning that he isn't
retiring from the national team I mean I
don't think he'll make it another world
cup cycle but uh you know the narratives
we want for these guys very often isn't
the narrative they want for themselves
you know uh uh
Tom Brady wants the moment not
the way all those moments are strung
together in some sort of you know like I
think they're chasing a feeling and you
know you know a lot more you know great
athletes than I do but everybody I've
ever talked to uh they don't miss
and they missed a feeling that you can't
ever get back of what it's like when it
matters that much and it's on you and
nothing in his life will ever ever
replace this and so I I imagine that you
know that there some great writer I
can't remember who now said you know
great athletes die twice you're a great
men died twice and I think that
certainly applies to athletes and uh you
know at least it's an indication that
he's self-aware that he didn't just bite
on the narrative and run off into the
sunset that he knows himself but you
know he's 35 I think which in soccer
terms is 109. so you know I mean it's
like dog years
what are you working on next
man I am writing a uh profile when I get
off of this it's what I'm going to go
back to do and I'm writing about Joe
Montana and I've spent a lot of time
with Joe Montana out in San Francisco
and uh I hope to be able to give you a
story about him that
feels like you
didn't know anything in it and uh I mean
I don't you know I'm very very excited
about it and uh Joe and Jennifer Montana
are uh are lovely interesting people and
I'm very excited about that give me a
nugget here
well uh when his uh he had a house in
Napa and there were those wildfires
several years ago and uh they came you
know they basically he said you got a
chance to come out here and save some
stuff because the fire is coming for
your house and they went out and you
know that's where all his football stuff
was and they went in they didn't grab
any of the football stuff all they
grabbed were uh uh albums of photographs
and pictures off the wall of the kids
they grabbed all of the kids artwork
that had that had sort of stuck up you
know stacked up over the years and then
they were about to leave and they're
like oh my God and they went back in and
got all of the Screaming Eagle Cabernet
can't can't believe that I mean we're
not animals
so but yeah I don't need any memorabilia
but I am not leaving 14 cases of
screaming eagle to burn
great to talk to you songs uh happy
holidays hope the girls are good and uh
we'll talk to you soon thanks Dan that's
right Thompson the book is the cost of
these dreams
and I've been around these athletes
obviously from the start of their career
to the end of their career but when you
read something that you had not heard
before that's when you know you're
reading somebody who's a great writer
and curious and that's what right is